everybody run it's coming it's coming
we're being attacked my bad Vijay in the
past anime and CG have not had I'm not
had the best public relationship the
general reaction from someone when they
hear the mere mention of CG being
integrated into their favorite anime is
that they pack up and start running a
[ __ ] mile like they've just found out
we're getting invaded by Nazis or even
more horrifyingly CG Nazis but today I
wanted to evaluate if CG really deserves
its reputation within the anime
community what are some examples of it
being used well and badly and what are
some of the different ways that CG have
been integrated into anime so first we
need to answer the question what is bad
CG and here's the catch you aren't
allowed to use any word that rhymes with
just summer 2017 well if we look at the
dictionary definition of bad CG we can
quite clearly see that all for [ __ ]
sake I'm sure we can all agree that it
is CGI a face that is noticeable enough
to take you out of your immersion and
break your suspension of disbelief and
out of place objects some stupid looking
expression a lot of things can take you
out of an experience but that's the
thing to keep in mind
bad CG is bad CG because you notice bad
CG bad CG sorry I just wanted to say bad
CG one more time I think a good place to
start is just seeing how the general use
and look of CG has evolved over time we
normally associate CG with more modern
age anime the CG effects have been
around for a lot longer than people
think and overtime has gotten better
blending in objects if you look at most
modern anime carefully you'd be
hard-pressed to find one that doesn't
incorporate some sort of computer
rendered object in it and a lot of the
time you don't notice because it's not
something that significant there's been
a lot of debate over how CG has changed
the general look of mechs over the years
and honestly I think it comes down to
how bland and forgettable modern mechs
feel they all move the same they all
feel the same with the same clunky video
game style that never looks quite as
natural as hand-drawn mechs nothing
becomes as memorable even if you have a
cool design I mean [ __ ] chamber from
sousei no gargantia had the thighs of a
seasoned Las Vegas poor dancer
this was never appreciated enough yeah
whether it be to speed up the production
time will make up for a lack of talents
who can animate mechs well it feels like
CG makes a use as a compensation tool
rather than a deliberate creative
decision because when done correctly
they look just as fantastic the
sequences of the unicorn transforming
look [ __ ] amazing and the reason they
do this is because they're done in CG
trying to animate this level of
complicated mechanical panel movement
would be absurdly difficult by hand if I
managed to make it not look like an in
engine video game cut scene however one
thing that the industry is still
figuring out how to do correctly is with
characters and it doesn't matter if they
are in the foreground or the background
there's an old Chinese proverb that goes
life is like a crosswalk full of
opportunity in every direction unless
that crosswalk contains a ceg anime
crowd in which case you're probably
burning in hell yeah CGI crowds are the
one thing I think are destined to always
look like complete [ __ ] nothing's more
distracting than when there's something
important going on but your brain is
unable to focus on anything but the same
five PlayStation 2 [ __ ] hanging
out in the background trying have rendus
Lee bad to blend in and I really did try
finding a good example of anime CGI
Krauss so if anyone does have any good
examples then please contact me at CGI
crowds that don't make my eyes wanna
come here suicide achieve male calm but
this extends the foreground characters
where you have to battle against this
weird uncanny valley effect where
characters kind of like anime but not
anime enough so when they're just there
front and center with no attempt to
blend it in your brain has time to
process what you're watching so you kind
of notice wait a minute these are the
same guys they hired to do the Mass
Effect Andromeda facial animations
even when they look competent when you
are restricted to 3d models emulating a
2d R star there is less freedom to work
with when it comes to subtle expressions
nuanced character animation and even the
best examples we've had so far don't
even come close to the best examples in
2d animation yet things are looking
better but the next problem is actually
being able to blend these two elements
the issue you face when you blend 2d
animation with 3d elements is the
aesthetic clash when we are watching an
animated show we know it is an animated
show that does not exist within our
universe but we are fully invested in
suspending our disbelief for that world
however if you see two objects that
blatantly look like they don't belong in
the same universe it worse against that
suspension of disbelief golden camo is
the latest example of this where you
have a standard anime characters
fighting back [ __ ] pair from bar by
five with a cel-shaded wolf in a
background of green screen fire effects
the visual cohesion is an absolute mess
and personally I much prefer this early
leak test footage as at least it has a
uniform visual star which you know it
just makes the fights just it's just far
more believable different aesthetics
only really work when the juxtaposition
is purposefully part of the visual style
or when it's supposed to happen
narrative Lee there are however
effective ways to blend the two elements
that we are seeing more often when CG is
limited to dynamic background
environments the fast-paced movement of
the foreground animation is only
enhanced allowing for more freedom of
camera movements which results in being
able to do complex shots like this
without giving the viewer adequate time
to notice the aesthetic clash there are
countless examples from attack on titan
to copious Akito the exiled even some of
the more intricate shot from war Nagar
tree which fully take advantage of this
or with other shows that had some shots
that were rotoscoped with the aid of CG
tools the important thing is that the CG
is never the main focus always rendered
in such a way that it naturally fits in
with the visual style of the show in
this sense ufotable
are the [ __ ] gods at this throughout
the years they have perfected the art of
digital composition and blending
traditional animation with
computer-aided effects to the point
where you can hardly tell the difference
my first exposure to them was their
first take on the fate franchise and no
no not you get the [ __ ] out of here
another time you blew me away and I
thought anime couldn't look better than
this but then they came back with
unlimited blade works and no not [ __ ]
you and have continually improved and
pushed the boundaries so much so that
they have crafted a unique visual style
which is instantly recognizable and no
one really calls this CG animators pite
how much they use it but moving on a
different problem from blending 2d and
3d is when you are completely switching
between the two let me set the scene
you're enjoying a classic show it looks
awesome the characters look great and
we're just about to get to the heart
pumping action scene then without any
warning it cuts to the action and you
noticed something's a bit off about the
way the show looks and then just as you
get used to it it switches back to
before and you like okay maybe my eyes
are being funny then you begin to look
really closely and slowly you realize
that maybe there is something different
about the way the show looks constantly
switching from 2d to 3d to 2d again is a
guaranteed method to make the viewer
feel a sense of visual whiplash and this
semi is right up there with CG crowds
for anime things that [ __ ] keep me up
at night
the most recent offenders I can think of
are with Ania Shiki and the berserk
movie trilogy and the thing is the CG
sometimes doesn't even look bad I
wouldn't even mind if some of these
shows were fully 3d it's just a note
don't shut shut the [ __ ] shut shut shut
the [ __ ] up just the constant switching
between visual styles that break any
kind of emerging you could be having and
I would prefer it so much if they just
chose one style and committed to it I
mean we've all heard of jazz hands but
have you tried the hottest trend Bad
CGPA what people don't normally talk
about however
is that the switch can be done well if
we stick to some of the same rules we
talked about killakee was a good example
if I tell you kill the kill used a lot
of CG your mind will probably go back to
that one time Satsuki was apparently
ice-skating vertically up a building
which how can I eloquently put this it
looks [ __ ] but what you probably don't
know is just how many cuts were
completely CG like this shot or this
shot or this entire sequence where they
built an entirely new 3d model just to
accentuates these few frames and unless
you were flicking through frame by frame
and know exactly what to look for you
won't even notice exactly because it was
the sky so well as opposed to being
lorded front and center but that leads
into the Big Daddy fully 3d anime if
there was a final boss for the anime
industry this would be it and for most
of the time so far anime has handled it
about as well as a Facebook surfing
candy crush addicted grandma attempting
and no hits run on Dark Souls the
problem with a lot of us had with early
CG anime was that they seemingly came in
with the approach of trying to emulate
the 2d art style with a completely
different tool and it doesn't take a
genius to tell you that if you aren't
using your tools correctly it probably
won't go well movement felt restricted
and robotic characters just weren't as
expressive the frame rate sometimes
looks really dodgy as they purposely
restricted it something even one guy who
helped make silly Internet videos
figured out was a dumb [ __ ] idea before
an entire industry did they didn't play
to their strengths but despite this as
time went on things began improving
acceptable shows started appearing we
slowly started to accept that maybe
there could be a space for CG anime and
just as we thought things were starting
to look up the 3rd 2016 came crashed
landing into the scene oh but it's okay
thanks to the collective effort of every
half piece of beep
come out we managed to stop this from
ruining everything quick polygon
pictures release something half decent
and maybe we can get out of it kimono
friends Nobunaga concierto kado these
were fully 3d shows that managed to be
enjoyable but the problem is I feel
these shows were enjoyable in spite of
its CG not because of it over the years
polygon pictures have tried their damned
hardest to make a case for fully 3d
anime and continually improves with
every project they work on but to me
it's the same problem there's nothing
that makes me think I would rather see
these shows using CG over traditional
animation if given an aesthetic choice
that is until we got the one show we
were waiting for land of the lustrous a
show like this was a long time coming
but despite how many opinions it changed
about CG anime it didn't really do
anything new that we haven't already
discussed what it did do was understand
what the strengths were for CG as a tool
and play to those strengths the CG
crystal effects of metallic textures
gave the show a unique visual identity
that wouldn't be a striking if it were
in 2d and the number of dynamic shots it
was able to pull off in his action
scenes chase eaves or just using long
shots to build this claustrophobic
tension is something that could only be
achieved using CG hopefully by the end
of this you can get the idea that
despite the reputation CG in anime has
right now CG can look good and has
looked good for years even if you're not
a fan of the aesthetics seen in polygon
pictures works or land of lustrous
you've probably appreciated it even if
you didn't know but that's just it it's
a lose-lose situation because if CG does
its job well it won't even be noticed
but if it does fail then it's forever
doomed to have some shitty anime
youtuber cement it into meme history
it's failures are exposed and its
successes are ignored but it's important
to note that whether it's good or bad
largely depends on the understanding
from the crater of the strengths and
limitations of working with CG as a tool
as it is with every other medium CG has
become a standard part of anime nowadays
so if you're not a fan of that then I
can suggest that you watch order anime
take the 80s for example computer
effects may have started to become
revolutionary in Hollywood but anime was
still untouched and pure you know back
then they would never ruin their anime
by rendering things using ugly
PlayStation 1 graphics because they were
too busy rendering things with a [ __ ]
guitar
2,600
[Music]
wait bro why is your helicopter bad CJ
what is your face bad CG well hey is
your life bad CG hey guys hope you
enjoyed the video thank you very much
this month to Sun fun down matey but
Lebanon big Black Hawk 16 sisters one
zero zero eight six Ella for Robert I'm
Borg and everyone else on my patreon for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible as you can
see I've changed my location back again
I am back in America and I will be
attending a X in LA in just a few weeks
I have a very busy schedule so if you're
going to be attending a X as well keep
an eye out for that as I'll be posting
that soon anyway that's it for me today
not too many updates but until then I've
been gig up and I will see you all next
time